You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道吗，你的眼睛承受了很大的压力。每天阅读、在昏暗的灯光下工作、长时间盯着屏幕——这种情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光，甚至夜间驾驶都会导致眼睛疲劳。所以，没错，我们的眼睛负担很重。因此，通过定期的眼科检查来呵护它们并监测其健康状况非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，费用仅需 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部疾病和健康问题。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. We've all been there, the unexpected hosting panic. Like when the watch party finally makes it out of the group chat, but you volunteered to host. And suddenly you need snacks, drinks, dips, cups, and all the other party essentials no one planned for. With Instacart, you can get all those groceries delivered in as fast as 60 minutes. No extra errands for you. One quick order for everyone. That way, everything shows up right on time,
要查找您附近的门店并预约 99 美元起的 OCT 扫描眼科检查，请访问 Specsavers。眼科检查由独立的验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。我们都有过这样的经历：突如其来的待客恐慌。比如当群聊里的聚会计划终于成行，而你却自告奋勇要当东道主。突然间，你需要零食、饮料、蘸酱、杯子以及所有没人提前计划好的派对必需品。有了 Instacart，你可以在最快 60 分钟内送达所有这些杂货。无需再额外跑腿。为大家下一份快速订单。这样，一切都能准时送达，
making hosting easy and making it look like you had it planned all along. Download the Instacart app today and get no markups at select retailers. Fees and in-store offer exclusions apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. There you guys.
让待客变得轻松，看起来就像你一直都在计划之中。立即下载 Instacart 应用程序，在指定零售商处享受零加价优惠。费用和店内优惠排除条款适用。我是 Jenna Fischer，我是 Angela Kinsey。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是《Office Ladies》6.0 版。你们好啊。
We wanted to take a break in our The Paper rewatch to share something really fun with you. We had a great time talking with Ed Helms on his podcast, Snap-Foo. Yes, Ed has a podcast and it's a lot of fun. Like Anch said, it's called Snafu, and we were his guest last year, but in case you missed it, we wanted to bring it to our feed today. And let me tell you, if you love deep dives, you are going to love snafu. Here's what happens. On each episode, Ed does a deep dive of a snafu moment from history. So we discussed that, but then, of course, we also talk a lot about our time on the office together.
我们想在重温《办公室》的间隙，与大家分享一些非常有趣的内容。我们曾在 Ed Helms 的播客《Snafu》上与他愉快地交谈。没错，Ed 有一个播客，而且非常有趣。正如 Angela 所说，它叫《Snafu》，我们去年曾做客他的节目，但以防你错过了，我们今天想把它带到我们的频道里。我得告诉你，如果你喜欢深度挖掘，你一定会喜欢《Snafu》。事情是这样的：在每一集中，Ed 都会深入探讨历史上一个“混乱时刻”（snafu）。所以我们讨论了那个话题，当然，我们也聊了很多关于我们一起在《办公室》工作的时光。
You know, it was very funny to me that the snafu moment that Ed picked to share with us takes place on a boat. And Angela, I can't believe that we did not bring up the fact that his character on the office, Andy, loves boats. I know. I mean, what a missed opportunity. Andy Bernard loves boats. But he also had several snafu moments on his family boat, the old 43-foot tart and sloop. And we're going to talk about things falling in the ocean. Andy had a snafu.
你知道，Ed 选择与我们分享的那个“混乱时刻”竟然发生在船上，这让我觉得非常有趣。Angela，我简直不敢相信我们竟然没提到他在《办公室》里的角色 Andy 非常喜欢船。我知道。我的意思是，这真是错失良机。Andy Bernard 热爱船只。但他也在他家的船上——那艘 43 英尺长的老式 Tartan 单桅帆船上——经历过几次“混乱时刻”。我们要聊聊东西掉进海里的事。Andy 就经历过一次混乱。
Was it his phone or his laptop? Remember it? It just slides in the ocean. Yes. Well, listen, it was really fun to catch up with Ed. So we hope you enjoy listening to us on his podcast. And next week, we'll be back for an all-new episode of Office Lady 6.0 as we continue are the paper breakdown. Now I know why they call it broken arrows. Because when you say, you know what, we have 32 broken arrows. You're like, oh, if you say we have 32 lost nuclear weapons, you're like, wait, stop?
是他的手机还是笔记本电脑？记得吗？它直接滑进了海里。是的。好吧，听着，和 Ed 叙旧真的很有趣。所以我们希望你喜欢听我们在他播客里的表现。下周，我们将带着《Office Ladies》6.0 的全新一集回归，继续我们的《办公室》剧集解析。现在我知道他们为什么叫它“断箭”（broken arrows）了。因为当你问，你知道吗，我们有 32 枚“断箭”。你会觉得，哦，如果你说我们有 32 枚丢失的核武器，你就会觉得，等等，停下？
What? Say again. Euphemisms make hard things a lot easier. Hey, I'm Ed Helms, host of Snafu, a show about history's greatest screw-ups. Today, I am joined by two of my all-time favorite humans on the planet, Angela Kinsey and Jenna Fisher. Of course, you know them as Angela Martin and Pam Beasley from the office, where we spent many years. Making each other chuckle both on and off camera. These days, they co-host the wildly beloved Office Ladies podcast, where they deep dive into every episode, every single episode of the office with their very own distinct brand of insight, warmth, heart, and hilarity.
什么？再说一遍。委婉语让困难的事情变得容易多了。嘿，我是 Ed Helms，《Snafu》的主持人，这是一个关于历史上最严重失误的节目。今天，我邀请到了我一生中最喜欢的两个人，Angela Kinsey 和 Jenna Fischer。当然，你们知道她们是《办公室》里的 Angela Martin 和 Pam Beasley，我们在那里度过了许多年。无论是在镜头前还是镜头后，我们都让彼此开怀大笑。如今，她们共同主持了广受喜爱的《Office Ladies》播客，她们以自己独特的洞察力、温暖、爱心和幽默感，深入挖掘《办公室》的每一集。
Angela and Jenna, I am so psyched. You're here. Hi, Ed. Hi, Ed. Yeah, it's so good to see you. I'm getting jazz hands right now because we've got video going. I just want to jazz it up a little. Jazz it up.
Angela 和 Jenna，我太兴奋了。你们来了。嗨，Ed。嗨，Ed。是的，见到你真好。我现在正兴奋地挥舞着双手，因为我们正在录制视频。我只是想让气氛活跃一点。活跃起来。
All right. Let me ask a very, I think very pressing question that all of our listeners and viewers are probably wondering right now, which is how much do you miss working with me on a daily basis? Oh, my gosh. I miss the office a lot. I know. I mean, we spend our days. Our job now is watching the show. And it always just brings up so many memories of working together.
好吧。让我问一个我认为所有听众和观众现在可能都在想的非常紧迫的问题，那就是你们有多怀念每天和我一起工作？哦，天哪。我非常怀念《办公室》。我知道。我的意思是，我们每天都在工作。我们现在的工作就是看这部剧。它总是勾起我们一起工作时的许多回忆。
And you know how many bloopers there are. Oh, yeah. There's so many because we would just laugh all day together. That's what we did. Ed, I miss, I miss being silly with you. Like, we would get so silly. Like, I would walk past you and we would just make up a new noise. Like pewing, wing, whing, whing.
而且你知道有多少花絮吗？哦，是的。太多了，因为我们整天都在一起大笑。这就是我们所做的。Ed，我怀念，我怀念和你一起犯傻的日子。我们总是会变得很傻。比如，我会从你身边走过，然后我们就会编造一种新的声音。比如 pewing, wing, whing, whing。
Like, p.oing, wing. Oh, my God. It's like all the stuff off camera, the life experience of that whole time. period, which was just had this kind of larger umbrella feeling of like, wow, we're all part of something really great. And that's like super special. But then we're also having these really mundane, lovely moments on the set just talking about each other's lives and families and like, I don't know, just the little, those little quiet moments or sitting at our trailers like waiting for a camera set up. or it's like that that's I think something that like fans don't always understand is that like our experience of making the show is actually this whole tapestry of mundane small moments of just
比如，p.oing, wing。哦，天哪。就像镜头之外的所有事情，那段时期的生活经历，它有一种更大的保护伞感觉，就像，哇，我们都是伟大事业的一部分。这真的很特别。但随后我们也会在片场经历那些非常平凡、可爱的时刻，只是谈论彼此的生活和家庭，或者，我不知道，只是那些安静的小时刻，或者坐在我们的拖车里等待摄像机设置。我觉得粉丝们并不总是理解这一点，那就是我们制作这部剧的经历实际上是由平凡小事组成的挂毯，只是
experiencing each other. I mean, it's an intimacy. Yeah. You know, of togetherness, of constant togetherness. Yeah. And I think if I could go back and relive a moment, like if, you know, I got a genie in a bottle and I could use a wish, it would be to go back and shoot a conference room scene all day. Because when we would see those on the script or on the call sheet and we would be like,
体验彼此。我的意思是，这是一种亲密感。是的。你知道，一种在一起的感觉，一种持续的在一起。是的。我想如果我能回到过去重温一个时刻，如果，你知道，我有一个神灯，我可以许一个愿，那我会选择回到过去，整天拍摄会议室的场景。因为当我们看到剧本或通告单上有这些场景时，我们会觉得，
oh, God, we got to be in the conference room. It's going to be a slog. Day. All day. But those were the days that created the moments you're talking about, Ed. Totally. Those little laughs, the shares, the sweatiness together, all of it. I also think because we weren't on a huge lot, you know, there wasn't.
哦，天哪，我们得去会议室了。这会是一场苦差事。一整天。但正是那些日子创造了你所说的那些时刻，Ed。完全正确。那些小小的笑声，分享，一起流汗，所有的一切。我还认为，因为我们不在一个巨大的场地，你知道，没有。
No distraction. You know, people didn't walk off to a commissary. We were just all in this little bubble, this tiny space where we got to be creative together. It kind of reminded me a little bit of that energy you have in your early days with your improv group or your one-act play, because there was no one else. There was no shiny object to go off and look at. It was just us. Like, I loved it when you would play your banjo and Creed would bring in his guitar and we'd hang out in the parking lot, you know? Yeah, and it's funny you bring up those conference room scenes because those were particularly special because most of the time we're not all together, right? Most of the time, we're just doing little scenes with like one or two other characters.
没有干扰。你知道，人们不会走去食堂。我们都待在这个小泡泡里，这个狭小的空间里，我们可以一起发挥创造力。这让我想起了你在即兴表演小组或独幕剧早期的那种活力，因为没有其他人。没有闪亮的东西可以去关注。只有我们。我喜欢你弹班卓琴，Creed 带着他的吉他，我们在停车场闲逛的时候，你知道吗？是的，你提到那些会议室场景很有趣，因为那些场景特别特别，因为大多数时候我们并没有聚在一起，对吧？大多数时候，我们只是和一两个其他角色演一些小场景。
And that's the bulk of our work. But then the table read was always a special moment. Every Tuesday morning was the table read of next week's script. Or two weeks. I forget the timing. Oh, it was one week. It was one week. One week.
那是我们工作的大部分。但剧本围读总是一个特别的时刻。每周二早上都是下周剧本的围读。或者是两周。我忘了时间了。哦，是一周。是一周。一周。
It was less than a week's notice. Yeah. But those are the moments, those and some of those conference room scenes were like, that's where everybody's together. Like everybody's. And those had a really special energy, like just a little buzz to them. And when, and like you said, when they were all day long, that's, and they get a little dull and they start to slow down. Everybody's trying to just hang in there. that's like some of the just most human hangout.
不到一周的通知。是的。但那些时刻，那些和一些会议室场景一样，那是每个人都在一起的地方。就像每个人都在。那些场景有一种非常特别的能量，就像有一点嗡嗡声。而且就像你说的，当它们持续一整天时，它们会变得有点枯燥，开始慢下来。每个人都只是试图坚持下去。那就像是一些最人性化的闲逛。
Ed, you had a really unique experience joining the show because you actually joined in Stanford. So you didn't start off in the Dunder Mifflin bullpen of the Scranton Dunder Mifflin bullpen. And then you came over. What was that like for you to kind of like soft launch into the show? Like you worked with John, you worked with Rashida, you worked with Chip. Yeah. Well, sorry, Jenna.
Ed，你加入这部剧的经历非常独特，因为你实际上是在斯坦福加入的。所以你并没有从斯克兰顿 Dunder Mifflin 的牛棚开始。然后你过来了。这对你来说是什么感觉，就像是软启动进入这部剧？你和 John 合作，和 Rashida 合作，和 Chip 合作。是的。好吧，抱歉，Jenna。
I'll be asking the questions today. I forgot his podcast we were doing. No, I love the question. I always tell people, like, that was such a gentle entry for us because of exactly what you're saying. Like, you know, Rashida and I started at a time when the show was hot. It was season three, and you guys had already just kind of, like, created this incredible thing. And so we were intimidated, but also felt kind of so warmly welcomed, both by the writers and all of you. Everyone's energy was so lovely.
我今天来问问题。我忘了这是我们做的播客了。不，我喜欢这个问题。我总是告诉人们，那对我们来说是一个非常温柔的切入点，正是因为你所说的。就像，你知道，Rashida 和我在剧集正火的时候加入。那是第三季，你们已经创造了这种不可思议的东西。所以我们感到很畏惧，但也觉得受到了热烈的欢迎，无论是编剧还是你们所有人。每个人的能量都非常可爱。
That's so sweet. It really could have gone the other way. I'm sure a lot of other shows, there's like more, it's more cutthroat or it feels more like, ah, the new people. Like, let's let them, they have to prove themselves. But I just felt so, like, all of my butterflies and anxiety just, washed out so quickly because everyone, all of you were so lovely right out of the gate, which is a testament to all of you and the vibe that got created. It was collaborative.
太甜了。它真的可能走向另一个方向。我相信很多其他节目，竞争更激烈，或者感觉更像是，啊，新来的人。让他们证明自己。但我感到非常，我所有的蝴蝶和焦虑都很快消失了，因为每个人，你们所有人都从一开始就非常可爱，这证明了你们所有人以及所创造的氛围。它是协作的。
It was not competitive. Totally. There was not like a weird, like, ego competitiveness going on on that set, which was so great. Absolutely. Yeah. It was always, you know, we always say it was a real creative collaboration from the writer's room to the crew to the cast. We're all working together to create a product that we were proud of.
它不是竞争性的。完全正确。那个片场没有那种奇怪的、自我竞争的东西，这太棒了。绝对。是的。你知道，我们总是说，从编剧室到剧组再到演员，这是一次真正的创意合作。我们都在一起努力创造一个我们引以为豪的产品。
And I think, I mean, I think you feel that when you watch it. And I think that's why people keep enjoying it is you're seeing a group of people having a great time. There's a warmth there that's real. And I think that comes through the camera. All right. Well, first, this is something I ask all of my guests. Is there a moment in your own life, a mishap, a misunderstanding, a full-blown meltdown that would qualify as a snafu? I mean, I have one that immediately comes to mind.
而且我想，我的意思是，我想当你观看它时，你会感觉到这一点。我想这就是为什么人们一直喜欢它的原因，你看到一群人玩得很开心。那里有一种真实的温暖。我想这通过镜头传达了出来。好吧。那么，首先，这是我问所有嘉宾的一个问题。在你自己的生活中，有没有一个时刻，一个失误，一个误解，一个彻底的崩溃，可以被称为“混乱时刻”（snafu）？我的意思是，我脑海中立刻浮现出一个。
What is it, lady? I had just moved from Indonesia to Dallas, Texas in the 80s. Okay, 1984. I had lived in Jakarta for 12 years. I didn't know what the heck an American high school vibe was. Oh, my God. And I was also a grade ahead in half my subjects. So I would go to the junior high for the first four classes.
是什么，女士？80 年代，我刚从印度尼西亚搬到德克萨斯州的达拉斯。好吧，1984 年。我在雅加达住了 12 年。我根本不知道美国高中的氛围是什么样的。哦，我的天哪。而且我有一半科目的成绩都超前了一个年级。所以我前四节课会去初中，
then my mom would pick me up. I'd eat lunch in the car, driving to the high school. And I was like this tiny little thing and this big high school. I was such an outsider. And I really wanted to fit in. And I'm a freshman who's moved from Indonesia, who doesn't know, like, I'm supposed to get a perm and wear a bunch of eyeliner. I don't know that yet.
然后我妈妈会来接我。我在车里吃午饭，开车去高中。我当时就像这个大高中里的一个小东西。我是一个彻头彻尾的局外人。我真的很想融入。我是一个从印度尼西亚搬来的新生，我不知道，我应该烫发并画很多眼线。我当时还不知道。
Yeah, Texas has a real, real specific high school vibe. especially in the 80s. 80s. 80s, Dallas. That's a vibe. Okay, first class of the day, English class, super hot dude behind me, like athletic dude. And I'm at my desk and my pencil on the desk rolls off to the right on the ground. I lean over to get it.
是的，德克萨斯州有一种非常、非常具体的高中氛围。特别是在 80 年代。80 年代。80 年代，达拉斯。那是一种氛围。好吧，当天的第一节课，英语课，我后面有一个超级帅的家伙，像运动员那样的家伙。我坐在桌子旁，桌上的铅笔滚到了右边的地上。我弯下腰去捡它。
I don't calibrate my weight versus the wraparound desk weight. Oh, no. The whole thing flipped over on me. pinned me to the ground with my feet akimbo. And the hottie dude behind me is like, oh my gosh. It goes to pick me up. And they were like, your arm. And I'm fine.
我没有校准我的体重与环绕式课桌重量的平衡。哦，不。整个东西翻到了我身上。把我钉在地上，双脚乱蹬。我后面的那个帅哥说，哦，天哪。他去扶我。他们说，你的手臂。我没事。
I'm fine. I'm fine. And my arm, I thought I broke my arm. Does this story end with the hottie asking you out? Because you've also just described like every meat cute in a teen movie from the 80s. I'm going to tell you right now, those meat cutts are a lie. All right. You got a quick one, Jenna?
我没事。我没事。我的手臂，我以为我摔断了手臂。这个故事的结局是那个帅哥约你出去吗？因为你刚才描述的就像 80 年代青少年电影里的每一次邂逅。我现在就告诉你，那些邂逅都是谎言。好吧。Jenna，你有一个简短的故事吗？
I do. So it's not a school snafu, but it's a teenage snafu. I had a big crush on one of the guys who lived in my neighborhood. And I kind of wanted to like just impress him, you know, like in that way where you want to peacock a little, maybe catch their eyes. So I had gotten this like new Esprit top. Do you remember Espray? Oh, yeah, of course. Very, very cool brand.
我有。所以这不是学校里的混乱，而是青少年时期的混乱。我当时暗恋住在我附近的一个男生。我有点想给他留下深刻印象，你知道，就像那种你想稍微炫耀一下，也许能引起他们注意的方式。所以我买了一件新的 Esprit 上衣。你还记得 Esprit 吗？哦，是的，当然。非常、非常酷的品牌。
And loved a spree. Very proud of it. And I had like this special like matching ribbon for my hair. So I put this on. And my, my idea was that I'd go out and get the mail. So it would be a reason for me to like walk out. So I timed it out.
我喜欢 Esprit。非常引以为豪。我还有一条特别的、配套的丝带系在头发上。所以我戴上了它。我的想法是，我出去拿邮件。这样我就有一个理由走出去。所以我计算好了时间。
I like sat and like watched him arrive home. And I proudly walked out in my spree top. And I went, I looked in the mailbox and like, oh, there's nothing there. But you know, I'm really looking as if, you know, it's okay. And he is, he is. watching me, right? Like, it's, I caught his eye. I get inside.
我坐着，看着他到家。我自豪地穿着我的 Esprit 上衣走了出去。我看了看邮箱，哦，里面什么都没有。但你知道，我真的表现得好像，你知道，没关系。而他，他正在看着我，对吧？就像，我引起了他的注意。我回到屋里。
My mom says, what are you doing? And I said, oh, nothing. I was just, I was just going to get the mail. And she said, sweetie, you're not wearing any pants. Oh, no. That's right. What? That's right.
我妈妈说，你在干什么？我说，哦，没什么。我只是，我只是去拿邮件。她说，亲爱的，你没穿裤子。哦，不。没错。什么？没错。
I forgot. I was so into my espree top that I forgot to put on the bottoms of the outfit, y'all. Like any bottoms? I mean, I had on like undies. Undies, but I didn't have on pants. This is like I had on this like long. It was kind of like an Oxford shirt. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
我忘了。我太沉迷于我的 Esprit 上衣了，以至于我忘了穿下装，伙计们。就像任何下装？我的意思是，我穿了内裤。内裤，但我没穿裤子。这就像我穿了一件长款的。它有点像牛津衬衫。是的，是的，是的，是的。
It hung down even past my underwear. Oh, this is very 80s. No, I was like, I was like Tom Cruise in, um, risky business. Just walking out in my big Oxford with no pants on. And then I hid in my house for the next four years and never spoke to him again. Oh, boy. I was so embarrassed. Those are some major snafews, you guys.
它甚至垂到了我的内裤下面。哦，这非常 80 年代。不，我当时就像，我当时就像《乖仔也疯狂》里的 Tom Cruise。穿着我的大牛津衬衫，没穿裤子就走出来了。然后我在家里躲了四年，再也没和他说过话。哦，天哪。我太尴尬了。你们这些都是重大的混乱时刻。
That's, yeah, that's big stuff. This one might be bigger. I hope so. Angela and Jenna, are you ready to dive into today's snafu? I'm so excited. I'm having a sip of my iced tea. All right. Get ready.
那是，是的，那是大事。这一个可能更大。我希望如此。Angela 和 Jenna，你们准备好深入探讨今天的“混乱时刻”了吗？我太兴奋了。我正在喝我的冰茶。好吧。准备好。
Get your popcorn. Ed, I love a snafu. I love you. I love this pod. So three of my favorite things are about to happen all at once. And I love Angela, my BFF. There you go. Four things.
准备好你的爆米花。Ed，我喜欢“混乱时刻”。我爱你。我喜欢这个播客。所以，我最喜欢的三件事即将同时发生。而且我爱 Angela，我的闺蜜。给你。四件事。
This is just an abundance of riches right here. It is. Today, Snapu takes us aboard the USS Ticonderoga, a massive aircraft carrier stationed off the coast of Japan in 1965. This thing was built like it was auditioning for a Cold War action movie. Tough exterior, fighter jets everywhere, total mid-century badass. Picture of Don Draper and Maverick from Top Gun had a baby. and the baby was a boat. And it like chain smoked all the time.
这简直是极其丰富的财富。确实。今天，《Snafu》带我们登上“提康德罗加号”航空母舰（USS Ticonderoga），这是一艘 1965 年驻扎在日本海岸附近的巨型航空母舰。这东西造得就像在为冷战动作片试镜一样。坚硬的外壳，到处都是战斗机，完全是中世纪的硬汉风格。想象一下 Don Draper 和《壮志凌云》里的 Maverick 生了个孩子，而这个孩子是一艘船。而且它总是没完没了地抽烟。
Like that's what this aircraft carrier was like. Pure American military swagger. Unfortunately, that swagger was about to trip into a colossal face plant. So what happened was what is known in military circles as a broken arrow incident. Do either of you know what that term means? There was a movie called Broken Arrow. Yes. There was.
就像这艘航空母舰一样。纯粹的美国军事狂妄。不幸的是，那种狂妄即将陷入一场巨大的惨败。所以发生的事情在军事圈被称为“断箭”事件。你们两个知道这个词是什么意思吗？有一部电影叫《断箭》。是的。确实有。
I don't. Do you know what the movie was about? It might get, it might help. Okay. I feel like a guy jumped off a train. Maybe that happened in that movie. But a broken arrow incident is that that's when we lose a nuclear device. Oh, my goodness.
我不知道。你知道那部电影是关于什么的吗？它可能会有帮助。好吧。我觉得有个家伙从火车上跳了下来。也许那件事发生在电影里。但“断箭”事件是指我们丢失了一个核装置。哦，我的天哪。
I think the nuclear device was on the train. Yeah. Okay, yeah. Okay, whatever. Let go. Let it go, Angela. I feel like John Travolta was in that movie. I can't remember anything else about it.
我想核装置在火车上。是的。好吧，是的。好吧，随便吧。放手吧。放手吧，Angela。我觉得 John Travolta 演了那部电影。我不记得关于它的任何其他事情了。
But anyway, the term broken arrow, that refers to any time we lose a nuclear missile or a bomb or device of some sort. And it happens, it has happened throughout history, numerous, like way more than you want to know. I mean, enough times they had to have a code name for it. Well, losing a nuclear weapon sounds completely insane. And it is. But part of why I wanted to bring this story to you guys in particular is that it has kind of a familiar flavor, clashing personalities, baffling miscommunication, questionable leadership choices. Basically, this is a classic workplace comedy.
但无论如何，“断箭”这个词指的是任何时候我们丢失了核导弹、炸弹或某种装置。它发生过，在历史上发生过很多次，多到你不想知道。我的意思是，次数多到他们不得不给它起个代号。好吧，丢失核武器听起来完全疯了。确实如此。但我特别想把这个故事带给你们的原因是，它有一种熟悉的味道，冲突的个性，令人困惑的沟通失误，值得怀疑的领导选择。基本上，这是一部经典的职场喜剧。
This is if Michael Scott was in charge. Yeah, yeah. And instead of cubicles, we're on a thousand foot warship in the middle of the Pacific Ocean. Instead of paper jams, we're dealing with hydrogen bombs. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Sometimes it can feel like everyone else has it all together. Their love life, even whether they're married or dating or dating. single, like they've got it figured out. But the truth is, I think we're all still figuring it out.
如果 Michael Scott 负责的话，就是这样。是的，是的。而且我们不是在隔间里，而是在太平洋中部的一艘千英尺长的军舰上。我们处理的不是卡纸，而是氢弹。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。有时你会觉得其他人一切都处理得很好。他们的爱情生活，无论是结婚、约会还是单身，就像他们已经搞定了一切。但事实是，我认为我们都还在摸索。
No matter where you are in your romantic journey, therapy is kind of great because you have someone to talk it out with, get advice from, kind of help you determine what you want and take some of that pressure off yourself. Yeah, and maybe to help unpack some elements of the past that might be holding you back, will better help therapists work according to a strict code of conduct. They are fully licensed in the U.S. and BetterHelp will offer you the therapist match commitment. You get a short questionnaire, you say your preferences, and they'll match you with someone. But guess what? If you don't like them, you can switch to a different therapist at any time. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally.
无论你处于浪漫旅程的哪个阶段，治疗都是一件很棒的事情，因为你有人可以倾诉，可以寻求建议，可以帮助你确定你想要什么，并减轻你自己的压力。是的，也许还可以帮助解开过去可能阻碍你的一些因素，BetterHelp 的治疗师遵循严格的行为准则。他们在美利坚合众国拥有完全的执照，BetterHelp 将为您提供治疗师匹配承诺。你填写一份简短的问卷，说明你的偏好，他们会为你匹配一个人。但猜猜怎么着？如果你不喜欢他们，你可以随时更换不同的治疗师。拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，BetterHelp 是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供服务。
Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterH-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. What's up guys? I'm Candace Dillard Bassett, and you may know me from my time on the Real Housewives of Potomac or as a part of the latest cast of The Traders. And I'm Michael Arsino, author of The New York Times Bestseller, I Can't Date Jesus. On our podcast, Undomesticated, we don't just say the quiet parents out loud, we're putting it all in the kitchen table and inviting you into the chaos. If you're ready for bold takes, real talk, and a little fun, come join us. Listen to and follow Undomesticated and Odyssey Podcast available wherever you get your podcast. On December 5th, 1965, just off the coast of Japan's Ryuku Islands, U.S. naval officers were running through a routine training exercise called the crew cut on the USS Taekonduroga.
注册并在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 获得 10% 的折扣。那是 BetterHELP.com/officeladies。大家好！我是 Candace Dillard Bassett，你们可能在《波托马克娇妻》中认识我，或者作为《叛徒》最新演员阵容的一部分。我是 Michael Arceneaux，《纽约时报》畅销书《我无法与耶稣约会》的作者。在我们的播客《Undomesticated》中，我们不仅说出那些安静的父母想说的话，我们还把一切都摆在厨房桌子上，邀请你进入混乱。如果你准备好迎接大胆的观点、真实的谈话和一点乐趣，快来加入我们。在任何你获取播客的地方收听并关注《Undomesticated》和 Odyssey Podcast。1965 年 12 月 5 日，就在日本琉球群岛海岸外，美国海军军官正在“提康德罗加号”航空母舰上进行一项名为“船员剪发”（crew cut）的常规训练演习。
An A4E Skyhawk, an attack fighter jet, was being wheeled into the elevator to be taken up to the flight deck. So quick pause. Are you guys nervous flyers? I am not, but I will say that for some reason the idea of landing or taking off on an air. Aircraft carrier scares the bejesus out of me. It's like, I don't know if it's the tiny runway or just the fact that it's surrounded by water or that it's constantly moving or that there's like 30 people on deck just casually waving around glow sticks. Like it's a rave for fighter james. I just, this is very unchill vibes for me.
一架 A4E 天鹰攻击机正被推上电梯，准备送往飞行甲板。快速暂停一下。你们是紧张的飞行员吗？我不是，但我得说，出于某种原因，在航空母舰上降落或起飞的想法让我吓得魂飞魄散。就像，我不知道是因为狭小的跑道，还是因为它被水包围，或者它在不断移动，或者甲板上有 30 个人在随意挥舞荧光棒。就像是战斗机的狂欢派对。我只是，这对我来说是非常不冷静的氛围。
Also, like with the short runway, don't they have like a cable that catches the plane and jerks it back? I mean, if you need a cable to catch your plane on a. landing. I don't know. What if you missed the cable? I got invited to do something like that. There was like, they invited me to be like in a cockpit for like a special flying mission thing. Cool. And I was like, I don't need to read anymore.
而且，像短跑道那样，他们不是有那种抓住飞机并把它猛拉回来的缆绳吗？我的意思是，如果你需要一根缆绳来抓住你的飞机降落。我不知道。如果你错过了缆绳怎么办？我被邀请去做类似的事情。他们邀请我进入驾驶舱进行某种特殊的飞行任务。很酷。我说，我不需要再读了。
Like, this is not going to go well for anyone. You're just going to have a lady throwing up on everyone. For this crew cut exercise, the pilot, Lieutenant Douglas Webster, was simply supposed to take off fly around for a bit and then land again, a routine drill to practice loading and unloading cargo. But almost immediately, things went off the rails. As the Skyhawk was being positioned on the elevator, it suddenly began rolling backward. The crew on the deck started waving frantically, shouting for Webster to hit the brakes. A few even ran behind the aircraft trying to stop it from rolling heroic, but not exactly
就像，这对任何人来说都不会有好结果。你只会有一个女士在每个人身上呕吐。对于这次“船员剪发”演习，飞行员 Douglas Webster 中尉本应起飞，飞一会儿，然后再次降落，这是一个练习装卸货物的常规演习。但几乎立刻，事情就失控了。当“天鹰”被放置在电梯上时，它突然开始向后滚动。甲板上的船员开始疯狂地挥手，大喊让 Webster 踩刹车。几个人甚至跑在飞机后面试图阻止它滚动，英勇，但不完全
realistic. The Skyhawk was one of the Navy's lighter planes. but it still had a take off weight of 24,500 pounds. So this was not a rogue shopping cart. This is like a tank with wings, basically. Somehow, Webster didn't catch on to all the chaos going on around him. And in a split second, the Skyhawk rolled off the side of the carrier, tore through the safety netting, and vanished into the ocean. What would you do if you're a crew member on this flight?
现实。天鹰是海军较轻的飞机之一，但它的起飞重量仍有 24,500 磅。所以这不是一辆流氓购物车。这基本上是一辆带翅膀的坦克。不知何故，Webster 没有注意到周围发生的混乱。在千钧一发之际，“天鹰”从航母侧面滚落，撕裂了安全网，消失在海洋中。如果你是这艘航母飞行甲板上的船员，你只是站在那里看着这一幕，你会怎么做？
deck and you're just like standing there watching this. Explitives. Some cursing. Who's getting fired? Someone's getting fired. Yeah, for sure. I would be like, we got to tell somebody. Have you ever like gone to sit down on the toilet and your phone's in your pocket and then it
脏话。一些咒骂。谁会被解雇？有人会被解雇。是的，肯定的。我会说，我们得告诉某人。你有没有像去坐马桶时手机在口袋里，然后它
falls in the toilet? Oh my God. That's my worst nightmare. That's never happened to me. Thank God. That's never, you've never dropped your phone in the toilet? No, I never have. Oh, my gosh.
掉进马桶里了？哦，我的天哪。那是我的噩梦。那从来没发生在我身上。谢天谢地。那从来没发生过，你从来没把手机掉进游泳池或水池里吗？那就是这让我想起的事情。好吧。但每次我走进机场厕所，比如机场的小便池，我都会因为那个原因把手机放进口袋。我太糟糕了。
I've done this before. I've never dropped your phone in a. swimming pool or something in a pool of water. That's what this is reminding me of. Okay. But every time I go into an airport bath, like the urinals in an airport, I'm just like, I pocket my phone for that exact reason. I'm so terrible.
因为如果我的手机掉进公共小便池，它就留在那里了。不，我不会把它拿出来的。它完了。再见手机。我想知道它是否，因为当它掉进海里时，它就没了。就像，它没了，你什么也看不见。我只是想知道有没有人想过要拉出那种，就像甲板上的船员问飞机在哪里？有人说，什么飞机？
Because if like my phone goes into like a public urinal, it's staying there. Like no, I ain't getting it out. It is done. Goodbye phone. I wonder if it was, because like when it dips, when it falls into the ocean, like, it's gone. Like it ain't, you can't see anything. And I just wonder if it went through anyone's head to just pull one of those like, like the crew on the deck is like where where's the plane? Somebody's like, what plane?
你在说什么？什么？什么？嗯？飞机？没有飞机？我不确定。还有其他飞机。
What are you talking about? What? What? Hmm? Plain? There was no plane? I'm not sure. There's other planes.
你知道吗？但这里没有飞机。这是另一架飞机。你怎么敢？自信的。你怎么敢问我那个？你只需要带着完全的、自信的反驳进来。什么？
You know what? But there was no plane here. Here's the other play. How dare you? The confident. How dare you ask me that? You just got to come in with like full, the confident rebuttal. What?
你怎么敢？两分钟前这里有一架飞机。不，有，什么？什么？我会知道的。我当时就站在那儿。我的工作是阻止它滚动。所以船员们采取了行动，呼叫附近的船只发起全面的搜救行动。
How dare you? There was a plane here two minutes ago. No, there were what? What? I would know. I was standing here. My job was to stop it from rolling. So the crew sprang into action, calling nearby ships to launch a full search and rescue operation.
但这不仅仅是为了找到深受爱戴的 Douglas Webster 中尉，他当时还在飞机里，就像它说的那样。哦，我的天哪。我没有。是的。是的。飞机里有一个人。我们不知道他是否还在飞机里。他在飞机里。
But it wasn't just about finding the beloved Lieutenant Douglas Webster, who was still inside the plane, as it's saying. Oh, my God. I didn't. Yeah. Yeah. There's a guy in the plane. We didn't know if he was still in the plane. He was in the plane.
我以为他是。哦，不。是的。哦，不。我知道。剧透警告。他没能活下来。哦。
I thought he was. Oh, no. Yeah. Oh, no. I know. Spoiler alert. He did not make it. Oh.
他没有被找回。那太可怕了。我知道。他是飞机里唯一的船员吗？是的。他是唯一一个丧生的人。哦，我的天哪。船上还有别的东西。
He was not recovered. That's terrible. I know. Was he the only crew member in the person in the plane? Yes. He's the only one who perished. Oh, my goodness. There was also something else on board.
一枚一兆吨的核弹。是的。作为参考，这比投在广岛的炸弹威力大 70 倍，用 Dunder Mifflin 的话来说，就像有人放错了一张非常重要的便利贴，如果那张便利贴也能蒸发一座城市的话。所以这整架巨大的飞机，带着超级核弹和这个可怜的人，就这样翻过了边缘。是的。他们就这样直接翻过了边缘。
A one megaton nuclear bomb. Yeah. For reference, that's 70 times more powerful than the bomb dropped on Hiroshima, which to put it in Dundermifflin terms is like someone misplacing a really important post-it note if that post-it note could also vaporize a city. So this whole enormous plane with the super-duper nuke and this poor man just go over the edge. Yes. They just go right over the edge.
而且我喜欢你刚才说的“超级核弹”（super-duper nuke）。感觉就像是。我想我相信那是技术术语。是的。你们装载超级核弹吗？哦，是的。准备好了。所以随后进行了疯狂的搜索。
And I love the term you just said super-duper nuke. It feels like it. I think that I believe that's the technical service. Yeah. Do you guys load the Super Doper Nuke? Oh, yeah. It's ready to go. So a frantic search followed.
但悲剧的是，飞行员和飞机都没有被找回。他们唯一找到的是他的头盔独自漂浮在海面上，这真的让人脊背发凉。所以事情是这样的。这不仅仅是“提康德罗加号”的一次随意巡航。它刚刚结束了在越南的战斗任务，正在前往日本进行急需的休息和加油。就在那时，不可避免的掩盖开始了。所以让我们分析一下舆论。
But tragically, neither the pilot nor the aircraft was ever recovered. The only thing they found was his helmet bobbing alone on the surface of the ocean, which really since chills down your spine. So here's the thing. This was not just a casual cruise that the Ticonderoga was on. It had just wrapped up combat duty in Vietnam. and was en route to Japan for some much-needed rest and refueling. And that's when the inevitable cover-up begins. So let's break down the optics for a second.
美国航空母舰，刚从战争中回来，在日本海岸附近意外投下了一枚核弹，这个国家，怎么说呢，对核弹有着非常具体的情感。这又是 1965 年，所以没过多久。哦，为了增加一点细节，我们签署了一项条约，承诺不会把核武器带到日本海岸附近。所以，是的，这不会有什么好结果。这艘船距离日本海岸线超过 200 海里吗？哦，我的天哪，你是谁？什么样的？这是一个非常具体的问题。
The U.S. aircraft carrier, fresh from war, accidentally drops a nuclear bomb just off the coast of Japan, a country with, let's say, a very specific set of feelings about nuclear bombs. This is, again, it's 1965, so not too much time has passed. Oh, and just for some added detail, we had signed a treaty promising we wouldn't bring nukes anywhere near Japanese shores. So, yeah, this was not going to go over well. Was the ship more than 200 nautical miles off the coastline of Japan? Oh, my God, who are you? What kind of? This is a very specific question.
好吧，我刚读到，我刚读到。我刚读到每个国家都有责任并拥有其海岸线外 200 海里的所有权。所以如果这在日本的 200 海里内，那是一个非常大的违规，因为你不是在公海。是的。我相信它完全在日本的管辖范围内。这是一个非常糟糕的形象。所以，当然，为了避免糟糕的形象，海军试图掩盖它。他们把它封起来，守口如瓶。
Well, I had just read that, I had just read that. I just read that every country is responsible and has ownership of the first 200 nautical miles off their shoreline. So if this was within Japan's 200 nautical miles, that is a very big breach because you're not an open ocean. Yeah. I believe it was well within Japanese jurisdiction. It was a very bad look. And so, of course, to avoid the bad look, the Navy tried to cover it up. They zipped it up, tight-lipped.
但正如我们所知，军事秘密最终总会潜入公众意识中。你们是好的秘密守护者吗？你们值得信赖吗？锁起来。锁起来。是的，但不是，这不是我能保守的秘密。是的。我会成为举报人。
But as we all know, military secrets have a way of slinking into the public zeitgeist eventually. Are you guys good secret keepers? Are you trustworthy? Lock it up. Lock it up. Yeah, but not, this is not a secret I could keep. Yeah. I would be a whistleblower.
我擅长保守你的秘密或 Angela 的秘密。或者朋友和家人的秘密，我自己的秘密。但如果你是军方，我不会为你保守我们在海里丢失了核武器的秘密。就像，我会成为那个写报告的女士。海军能够极其，或者也许令人恐惧地隐瞒这一事件超过 15 年。直到 1981 年，五角大楼才披露了这一事件。《华盛顿邮报》报道了它。
I'm good at keeping your secrets or Angela's secrets. or friends and family secrets, my own secrets. But I'm not going to keep your, we lost a nuclear weapon in the ocean secret for you if you're the military. Like, I'm going to be the lady who is writing a report on that. The Navy was spectacularly or perhaps frighteningly able to conceal this incident for over 15 years. It wasn't until 1981 that the Pentagon disclosed the incident. The Washington Post reported about it.
仅仅用了三句话埋在核事故报告中。然而，五角大楼的人也没有费心解释炸弹到底在哪里的细节。他们首先声称炸弹距离陆地超过 500 英里。模糊吗？他们还向所有人保证，炸弹不会造成任何危险，因为它在水下 16,000 英尺处。但在 1989 年，环保组织绿色和平组织，连同海军专家 William Arkin，曝光了更多海军文件，揭示了炸弹仅投在距离琉球群岛海岸 70 英里的地方，而不是他们之前说的 500 英里。他们还指出，这一事件违反了日本严格的无核政策，并暴露了一些关于越南核武器的严重海军秘密。
in a mere three sentences buried in a nuclear accidents report. However, the folks at the Pentagon also did not bother explaining the details of where exactly the bomb was. They first stated that the bomb was more than 500 miles from land. Vague much? They also assured everyone that the bomb posed no danger since it was 16,000 feet underwater. But in 1989, the Environmental Group Group Group, Greenpeace, alongside naval expert William Arkin, exposed more naval documents, revealing that the bomb was dropped only 70 miles off the coast of the Ryuku Islands, as opposed to the 500, they had said before. They also pointed out that this incident violated Japan's strict anti-nuclear policies and exposed some serious Navy secrets about nuclear weapons in Vietnam.
别无选择，五角大楼最终承认了整个行程。关于这个巨大的混乱时刻，在同一年 1989 年的一份声明中。这是否给美国和日本政府造成了外交问题？是的。在 1989 年？是的。肯定的。感觉这些国际事件总是，总是有某种程度的姿态
With no other choice, the Pentagon finally admitted the whole trip. about this gigantic snafu in a statement that same year in 1989. Did this create a diplomatic issue for the United States and the Japanese government? Yeah. In 1989? Yeah. For sure. It feels like these international incidents are, there's always some measure of just sort of posturing
就像，我们必须这样回应，因为协议要求我们这样做。所以我们必须发表这些声明，我们必须说这些话。我们必须说我们很愤怒。然后美国必须用他们的外交解释和承担责任来回应。这太编排了，所有这些事情。这一切如何运作真是太疯狂了。然后我总是想，有人真的会把这当回事吗？
of like, we have to respond this way because protocol demands it of us. And so we must make these statements and we must say these things. And we must say that we're outraged. And then the U.S. must respond with their, like, diplomatic explanation and acceptance of responsibility. It's like, it's so choreographed all these things. It's very wild how it all works out. And then I always wonder, like, does anyone actually take this personally?
如果，比如，日本表达愤怒，就像，他们怎么敢？有没有什么日本官员，就像，在个人层面上真正生气？还是这只是一种宏大的制度情绪？我也很好奇，超级核弹会发生什么？超级核弹？超级核弹。它会被加压吗？70 英里外的水有多深？这是一个很好的问题。绿色和平组织对此有很多话要说。好吧。所以当五角大楼在 1989 年承认这一点时，他们实际上是在回应《新闻周刊》的一篇文章。然后日本报纸报道了这个故事，这当然在日本国内引起了相当大的轰动，理所当然。虽然五角大楼证实炸弹不会有害，它没有被武装，
If, like, Japan is expressing outrage, like, how dare they? Is there any, like, Japanese official who's, like, genuinely pissed, like, at a personal level? Or is it just sort of like grand institutional emotion? I'm also curious, what, what happens to a nuclear, a super dupe nuke? Super duper nuke? A super duper nuke. Does it get pressurized? How deep was the water 70 miles off? This is a great question. And Greenpeace had a lot to say about this. Okay. So when the Pentagon admitted this in 1989, they were actually responding to an article in Newsweek. And then Japanese papers picked up the story, which of course caused quite a stir throughout Japan itself, rightfully so. Though the Pentagon confirmed that the bomb would not be harmful, it hadn't been armed,
而且你必须经过一整套程序要素才能真正武装它，它仍然在水下 16,000 英尺处腐烂，这意味着它可能最终会分解并开始排放严重的污染物。然而，美国发言人声称这不会对自然界造成任何伤害。无论如何，可以肯定地说他们处于风口浪尖，至少像那枚炸弹里的核材料一样热，我们可以这么说。所以虽然许多人理所当然地对那个大“噗通”感到愤怒，但更多人感到愤怒是因为，事实上，这艘船根本就不应该携带那枚炸弹。是的，在事件发生时，日本有核武器禁令。而且两个世界大国之间显然有一个不成文的协议。
and you have to go through a whole bevy of procedural elements to actually arm it, it was still 16,000 feet underwater decaying, which meant it might eventually break down and start to emit serious pollutants. Yet, U.S. spokespersons claimed this wouldn't cause any harm to the natural world. Either way, it was safe to say they were in the hot seat, at least as hot as the nuclear material inside that bomb, shall we say. So while many were rightfully mad about the big Kerkrplunk, more were outraged because, in fact, the ship shouldn't have had the bomb on it in the first place. Yes, at the time of the incident, Japan had a ban on nuclear weapons. And there was apparently an unspoken agreement between the two world powers.
日本官员会故意不问美国船只携带什么，美国也不会主动提供任何信息。这是那种“不问，不说”的情况之一。所以到底发生了什么？这一事件引发了关于通过日本的外交询问在美国战斗中使用核武器的进一步问题。它还质疑我们如何遵守某些安全协议和标准，特别是在涉及高功率武器时。
Japanese officials would intentionally not ask the U.S. ships what they were carrying, and the U.S. wouldn't volunteer any info either. It was one of those sort of like don't ask, don't tell kinds of situations. So what happened exactly? The incident fueled further questions about the use of nuclear weaponry in U.S. combat via diplomatic inquiry from Japan. It also called into question how we adhere to certain protocols and standards for safety, especially when it involves high-powered weapons.
以及在航空母舰周围移动飞机。另外，你知道，它巩固了对美国公众撒谎的长期传统。自 1950 年以来，不知何故发生了多达 32 起“断箭”事件。这包括盗窃。等等，等等。是的，举手。什么？32 枚超级核弹。
and moving planes around aircraft carriers. Plus, you know, it solidified the longstanding tradition of lying to the American public. Since 1950, there have somehow been a whopping 32 broken arrow incidents. This includes theft. Wait, wait. Yeah, raising hands. What? 32 super duper nukeers.
以及在航空母舰周围调动飞机。此外，你知道，它巩固了向美国公众撒谎的长期传统。自1950年以来，竟然发生了多达32起“断箭”事故。这包括盗窃。等等，等等。是的，举手。什么？32枚超级核武器。
Gone? Super duper nukeers. 32 lost nuclear weapons. Ooy, yoy. Now I know why they call. Call it broken arrows. Because when you say, you know what, we have 32 broken arrows. You're like, oh, if you say we have 32 lost nuclear weapons. You're like, wait, stop. What? Say again. Euphemisms make hard things a lot easier. Oh, man. Yeah. Yeah. 32. That's why Greg called all of our talking heads candy bags, you know. I forgot that. He said that he always felt bad giving us pages and pages of extra monologues. So he was like, I'll name them something fun. So he named him something fun. So he named him. I loved those. I loved doing those talking heads and like coming up with like new riffs and like
丢了？超级无敌核武器。32枚核武器丢失。哎呀。现在我知道他们为什么叫它“断箭”了。因为当你直接说“我们有32枚断箭”时，你不会觉得有什么，但如果你说“我们丢了32枚核武器”，你就会想“等等，停下，什么？再说一遍”。委婉语让棘手的事情变得容易接受多了。天哪，是啊，32枚。这就是为什么格雷格把我们所有的访谈片段称为“糖果袋”，你知道的。我忘了这事了。他说他总是因为给我们那么多额外的独白页而感到内疚，所以他想给它们起个有趣的名字。所以我很喜欢那些访谈片段，喜欢想出新的即兴发挥。
the candy bag, allts, like all the different versions of our talking heads. Like just it was like getting a window into the writer's brains. I just remember loving the math of those jokes and like always trying to think about how to heighten them and they'd have to kick me out of those talking heads. But to your point, naming all the extra work a candy bag. It's a trick. Definitely made it go down easier. And also, calling all our screw-ups bloopers makes them sound fun, too. Like, oh, that was a blooper. Like, that's just a broken arrow. I mean, even the word snafu is kind of fun.
“糖果袋”，还有各种不同版本的访谈片段。就像是窥探编剧大脑的一扇窗。我记得我当时很喜欢那些笑话的逻辑，总是试图想办法让它们更出彩，他们不得不把我从那些访谈中赶出来。但说到把额外的工作称为“糖果袋”，这确实是个小花招，让工作变得更容易接受了。而且，把我们的失误称为“花絮”也让它们听起来很有趣。就像“哦，那只是个花絮”。那其实就是个“断箭”。甚至“snafu”（混乱）这个词听起来也挺有趣的。
It's a snafu. Guys, it's just a snafu. Oupsie. Whoopsy-doozy. Yeah. So these 32 broken arrow incidents include theft, accidental detonation, and just straight-up loss, like the one that rolled off the back of the. the taekondroga.
这就是个混乱。伙计们，这只是个混乱。哎呀，小失误。是的，所以这32起“断箭”事故包括盗窃、意外引爆，以及直接丢失，就像那个从提康德罗加号后面滚下去的那个。
Like, yeah. I don't know, like, which one bothers me the most. I don't know if it's that we lost some, that they were stolen or accidentally detonated. Like, they're all three of those. I don't know which one's worse. I feel like theft is the scariest. Thest. Yeah.
是啊。我不知道哪一个最让我困扰。我不知道是因为我们丢了一些，还是它们被偷了，或者是意外引爆了。这三者都是。我不知道哪个更糟。我觉得盗窃是最可怕的。
I do too. But the next time you're feeling clumsy for dropping something, just remember that the U.S. Navy dropped an entire hydrogen bomb into the ocean and then kicked sand over it for 15 years. and they got away with it. So the lesson here, guys, is lie. If you mess up, lie about it. Because then 15 years will go by. That's the lesson.
我也这么觉得。但下次当你因为弄丢东西而感到笨手笨脚时，记住美国海军曾把一枚完整的氢弹掉进海里，然后掩盖了15年，而且他们还逃脱了惩罚。所以这里的教训是：撒谎。如果你搞砸了，就撒谎。因为15年后一切都会过去。这就是教训。
That's the takeaway. Because then 15 years will go by. And then it's like nobody really gets in trouble. There's a little bit of saber rattling. And like people get like the like governments get mad and exchange sort of diplomatic, you know, zingers at each other. But it's not really like a thing. So yeah.
这就是结论。因为15年后，没人会真的惹上麻烦。只会有一点点虚张声势，政府之间会感到愤怒，并交换一些外交上的“讽刺”。但这并不是什么大事。所以，是的。
I guess that's the lesson. Do you think there are any other valuable lessons here, guys? I think there's a second part to that. It would be lie plus time. Give it time. Lie for a long time. Be patient with your lie. I think what you're saying is hold your lies deep inside of you for a really long time.
我想这就是教训。你们觉得还有其他有价值的教训吗？我觉得还有第二部分。那就是“谎言加时间”。给它时间。撒谎撒久一点。对你的谎言要有耐心。我想你的意思是把谎言深深地藏在心里很久很久。
Hold those secrets. Not other people's secrets, your secrets. Hold them deep. Let them devour you from the inside. Such a positive message. I know. Snap. But in all seriousness, is there any, like, positive takeaway here?
守住那些秘密。不是别人的秘密，是你自己的秘密。深藏起来。让它们从内部吞噬你。真是个积极的信息。我知道。啪。但说真的，这里有什么积极的收获吗？
Like, is there a way to frame this or look at this that, like, gives us a good lesson? Yeah. Thank you, Greenpeace. Amen. Thank you. I love it. Way to stand for something and hold people accountable. Like, thank goodness you're around because maybe we would have never known, right?
有没有一种方式可以从积极的角度来看待这件事？有的，感谢绿色和平组织。阿门。谢谢。坚持立场并让人们承担责任。谢天谢地有你们在，否则我们可能永远都不会知道，对吧？
Because they seem like they were really sounding the alarm. on this. Yep. They were pissed. Yeah. About all this stuff. Yeah. They were pissed.
因为他们看起来确实是在为此敲响警钟。是的。他们很生气。关于所有这些事情。是的。他们很生气。
They were not going to let this just be swept under the rug. It is hard to believe, like, despite what the Pentagon said, it's like, it's hard to believe that a nuclear missile just decaying on the bottom of the ocean is like completely harmless. It's kind of hard to believe. It doesn't make any logical sense. I mean, what is that going to do to the ocean and the ecosystem around it? It's probably going to kill a couple of starfish. It's going to take out a few coral reefs.
他们不会让这件事就这样被掩盖。很难相信，尽管五角大楼那么说，但很难相信一枚核导弹在海底腐烂是完全无害的。这很难让人相信。这在逻辑上说不通。我的意思是，这对海洋和周围的生态系统会有什么影响？它可能会杀死几只海星，摧毁一些珊瑚礁。
I would also say that what is leaking there, I'm not saying it's this one nuke, but there are all these studies about what's in our fish. There's like all kinds of scary heavy metals in the fish. I mean, would you take a dirty penny and put it in a glass of water and let it sit overnight and then drink that glass of water the next day? You wouldn't. You wouldn't. I mean, come on. It's doing something down there. For sure.
我还要说，那里泄漏的东西，我不是说就是这枚核弹，但有很多关于鱼类体内成分的研究。鱼类体内有各种可怕的重金属。我的意思是，你会拿一枚脏硬币放进一杯水里，放过夜，然后第二天喝掉那杯水吗？你不会的。你不会。拜托，它在海底肯定会造成影响。
Can I just bring us back? Bring us back. For a little callback here. I think instead of broken arrow, they should be called a dirty penny. Thank you, Angela. I like that. Got some dirty pennies to account for you guys. Yeah, that's right.
我能把话题拉回来吗？拉回来。做一个小小的呼应。我觉得与其叫“断箭”，不如叫它们“脏硬币”。谢谢你，安吉拉。我喜欢这个。你们有一些“脏硬币”需要交代。是的，没错。
Now, tell me what you guys are up to and what we need to look out for you. What's next on office ladies? How many episodes have you done and how many are left, by the way? Well, we have watched every episode of the office. And we have given you all the behind the scenes, details, and trivia that we have collected from cast and crew members for every single episode. And we still have new episodes coming out every Wednesday. Amazing. We have our whole office rewatch library that is playing on Mondays.
现在，告诉我你们在忙什么，我们需要关注你们什么。Office Ladies接下来有什么安排？顺便问一下，你们已经做了多少集，还剩多少集？嗯，我们已经看完了《办公室》的每一集。我们已经为每一集提供了从演职人员那里收集到的所有幕后细节和花絮。我们每周三仍然会有新剧集发布。太棒了。我们有完整的《办公室》重温库在周一播放。
And on Wednesdays, we have all new material, all new fun stuff. dive in deeper into the world of the office and our best friendship. It's super fun. Come hang out with us. Yeah, I'd love to. Are you kidding me? Jenna, tell them about your play. Tell me about your play. I am doing a play at the Goodman Theater in Chicago called Ashland Avenue. It's a world premiere written by Lee Kirk. You might have heard of him. Oh, yeah. My husband married to the writer, no big whoop. That's so cool. And starts previews on September 6th, and it opens on September 15th, and you can get tickets. at goodmantheater.org. I'm really excited. This will be my first time back on stage in about eight years. And, you know, theater is my first love. So I'm really excited. That is so cool, Jenna. I'm so excited
周三我们有全新的内容，所有有趣的新东西。深入挖掘《办公室》的世界和我们最好的友谊。超级有趣。来和我们一起玩吧。是的，我很乐意。你在开玩笑吗？珍娜，告诉他们你的戏剧。告诉我你的戏剧。我正在芝加哥古德曼剧院演一部叫《阿什兰大道》的戏。这是李·柯克编剧的世界首演。你可能听说过他。哦，是的。我丈夫，嫁给了编剧，没什么大不了的。太酷了。9月6日开始预演，9月15日首演，你可以在goodmantheater.org买票。我真的很兴奋。这将是我大约八年来第一次回到舞台上。你知道，戏剧是我的初恋。所以我真的很兴奋。太酷了，珍娜。我真为你感到兴奋。
for you. Anne Lee, that is just awesome. Thank you. And this is the Goodman Theater's 100th year. So this is their centennial season and we'll be kicking it off with Ashland Avenue. No big deal. No big deal, though. And Angela, Angela's got some fun news as well. I do. So, you know, You know, Ed, my husband's a chef and a baker, and he's self-taught, and he's really big about getting the family in the kitchen and cooking together and baking together, and that the kitchen is the heart of our home, and he's been making recipes, and we've been cooking together for years now, and he's finally put all of our favorite family recipes into a cookbook. It's called You Can Make This, because that's what he says to me and the kids all the time.
还有李，这真是太棒了。谢谢。今年是古德曼剧院成立100周年。所以这是他们的百年纪念季，我们将以《阿什兰大道》拉开序幕。没什么大不了的。真的没什么大不了的。安吉拉也有一些有趣的消息。是的。所以，你知道，埃德，我丈夫是个厨师和面包师，他是自学的，他非常热衷于让家人一起在厨房做饭和烘焙，厨房是我们家的核心，他一直在研究食谱，我们已经一起做饭好几年了，他终于把我们最喜欢的家庭食谱整理成了一本食谱。书名叫《你可以做这个》，因为他总是对我还有孩子们这么说。
He's like, you guys can make this. And you really can. And so we have that coming out in October of this year. And it's really great. It's a great, great cookbook. Congratulations. That's so, so cool. Thank you.
他说：“你们可以做这个。”而且你们真的可以。所以这本书将在今年10月出版。真的很棒。这是一本非常非常棒的食谱。恭喜。太酷了。谢谢。
I'm excited to tell you about my book coming out in another year called Super Dooper Newker. Not true. Hey, you guys are the best. And I am just so, so happy to see you and hang out with you a little. little bit. Every time I get a chance to see you, it's just the best. Thanks for coming on. Oh, thanks for having us, Ed. You're awesome. We love you. Snapu is a production of I-Heart Podcasts and Snafu Media, a partnership between Film Nation Entertainment and Pacific Electric Picture Company. Our post-production studio is Gilded Audio.
我很兴奋地告诉你们我明年要出版的书，叫《超级无敌核武器》。开玩笑的。嘿，你们是最棒的。能见到你们并和你们待一会儿，我真的非常非常高兴。每次有机会见到你们，都是最棒的。谢谢你们来参加。哦，谢谢邀请我们，埃德。你太棒了。我们爱你。Snafu是I-Heart Podcasts和Snafu Media联合制作的，这是Film Nation Entertainment和Pacific Electric Picture Company之间的合作。我们的后期制作工作室是Gilded Audio。
Our executive producers are me, Ed Helms, Mike Falbo, Glenn Bazner, Andy Kim, Whitney Donaldson, and Dylan Fagan. This episode was produced, by Alyssa Martino and Tori Smith. Our video editor is Jared Smith, technical direction and engineering from Nick Dooley. Our creative executive is Brett Harris, logo and branding by The Collected Works, legal review from Dan Welsh,
我们的执行制片人是我、埃德·赫尔姆斯、迈克·法尔博、格伦·巴兹纳、安迪·金、惠特尼·唐纳森和迪伦·法根。本集由艾丽莎·马蒂诺和托里·史密斯制作。我们的视频剪辑师是贾里德·史密斯，技术指导和工程由尼克·杜利负责。我们的创意执行是布雷特·哈里斯，标志和品牌设计由The Collected Works负责，法律审查由丹·威尔士负责，
Megan Halson, and Caroline Johnson. Special thanks to Isaac Dunham, Adam Horn, Lane Klein, and everyone at IHeart Podcasts, but especially Will Pearson, Kerry Lieberman, Nikki Eitor, Nathan Otoski, and Alex Corral. While I have you, don't forget to pick up a copy of my book, Snafu, the definitive guide to history's greatest screw-ups. It's available now from any book retailer.
梅根·哈尔森和卡罗琳·约翰逊。特别感谢艾萨克·邓纳姆、亚当·霍恩、莱恩·克莱恩以及IHeart Podcasts的所有人，特别是威尔·皮尔逊、克里·利伯曼、尼基·艾托、内森·奥托斯基和亚历克斯·科拉尔。趁现在，别忘了买一本我的书《Snafu》，这是历史上最伟大失误的权威指南。各大书店均有销售。
Just go to snafu-dashbook.com. Thanks for listening and see you next week. I felt like I learned so much. I did not know how many broken arrows there had been. And I love Ed's podcast. This is its fourth season. It's just so great. It really is.
直接去snafu-dashbook.com。感谢收听，下周见。我觉得我学到了很多。我以前不知道竟然有这么多“断箭”事故。我喜欢埃德的播客。这是第四季了。真的很棒。确实如此。
We love a deep dive. I love learning new things. And plus Ed is so charming. So it's a win-win. You know, he also wrote a book called Snafu, The Definitive Guide to History's Greatest Screw-Ups. It's a New York Times bestseller and here's a little blurb about it. Ed Helms brings you an absurdly entertaining look at history's biggest blunders, complete with lively illustrations. Well, we each have a copy and it's terrific. And we'll share a link to it in our stories. Well, thanks for listening, everyone. We'll see you next week as we break. break down episode six of the paper. See you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
我们喜欢深度挖掘。我喜欢学习新东西。而且埃德很有魅力。所以这是双赢。你知道，他还写了一本书叫《Snafu：历史上最伟大失误的权威指南》。它是《纽约时报》畅销书，这里有一段关于它的简介。埃德·赫尔姆斯带你以一种荒诞有趣的方式回顾历史上最大的失误，并配有生动的插图。嗯，我们每人都有副本，非常棒。我们会在我们的故事中分享链接。好了，感谢大家的收听。下周见，我们将解析《办公室》的第六集。下次见。感谢收听Office Ladies。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是安斯利·布比科。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。Office Ladies由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。